I want to take up in Vol. 13 at August the 20th, 1921. The acts on in the divine will
are heavens of love and of glory.
"Continuing my state of privation," Louisa said, "and my state of unspeakable bitterness,
my beloved Jesus came for just a little, and surrounding me with these arms," he told
me. That's Song of Songs 2.6.
"My daughter, daughter of my will, I love so much one who lives in my will, so much that
I become her custodian, and I keep her sheltered in my arms. I am jealous that not even one
act be lost, because in each act there is the involvement of my very life. So I want
to give you Deuteronomy 32.11, the Lord alone was his guide.
The fiat, Jesus said, was issued at the creation, and from the fiat, creation receives continuous
preservation. If my fiat withdrew, creation would return to nothing.
And if creation remains intact without changing, it is because it has not moved from my fiat.
So there you have the fiat of the Lord is the origin of all things, and the origin of
all life. So if creation remains intact without changing, it's because it has not moved from
my will. Now notice that if we remain without changing within his will, everything that
he wants to do can be done in us. However, I did not repeat another fear, Jesus said.
Otherwise more new heavens, more new suns and stars would have come out each different
from the other, because with God there is infinite variety. On the other hand, in the
soul, in the soul who lives in my will, there's not just one Fiat, but repeated Fiat's.
In other words, the new creation, the Lord is working in us is an extraordinary tragedy.
Therefore, as the soul operates in my will, I repeat the Fiat and new heavens, new suns,
new stars are extended in the soul, because that's where he's working. And since the
soul contains an intelligence, these heavens are new heavens of love, glory, light, adoration
and knowledge. In other words, they are new spiritual heavens. What the Lord does in us
is that he makes a tabernacle for himself. He makes a temple of God on the earth. He
makes a space where God can live and God can move and God can act. That's 1 Corinthians
3 16 and Luke 17 21, the kingdom of God is within you. And so he creates a divine sanctity
within us. He says, "It forms such a variety of beauty that I myself remain enraptured.
The whole of heaven, the saints, the angels cannot take their gaze from this soul, because
as they admire the variety of heavens which she contains, more new ones extend, each more
beautiful than the other. They see the celestial fatherland copied in the soul, who lives
in my will. They see the multiplicity of new things which multiply it to the infinite.
So here you have heaven created in the soul. But St Elizabeth of the Trinity says that,
when she preceded Louisa, she had an extraordinary relationship with the Father, the Son and the
Holy Spirit, and she said she was living heaven on earth, because heaven is the home
of the Father, the Son and the Holy Spirit. And if they are living and operating in us,
heaven is in us. And what the Lord tries to do with us is to create more space for him
to create more heavens in us. So he's a creator. And there's a great mystery here, because
if you take the cell of the human body, it has a nucleus and it has mitochondria and various
things going around it. If you look at the solar system, the nucleus is the Sun with the
other planets going around it. It's exactly the same structure. If we examine the heavens
above our heads, it's the same structure as the extraordinary mystery that is within
us. As an astrophysicist said recently, if we only understood we are indeed star children.
The heavens are in us and we are in them. So it is an extraordinary thing that the Lord
is trying to do is to create new heavens within us, because he's all the time looking for
space to do something new. Throughout the Scriptures, he has repeatedly said, "Behold,
now make all things new." He's continuously wanting to do something new. Isaiah said,
"I think it is in Isaiah 43, there's no need to remember the past. Behold, I am doing
a new thing. It's only coming to light now. Can you not see it?" But you don't need to
remember what was passed. And it's same with us when we come into the divine will, that
our past lives, in fact, it doesn't matter anything about them. That was then. But now
we are a space for God to work. And we give him a throne on earth so that he can live
and reign and work among humanity on this planet. So let me read that again. The whole
of heaven, the saints, the angels, cannot take their gaze from this soul, because as they admire
the variety of heavens which he contains, more new ones extend. That means are created every moment,
even more beautiful than the other. They see, they are the saints and the angels.
They see the celestial fatherland copied in the soul. Now I don't really want to go too far off
the page, but I do want you to know that if you go back to the book of Exodus, that you will find
that when Moses set up the tabernacle in the wilderness, and he formed the worship of the
people to try and show them what it was like to be a people of God, he told them that the pattern
of the tabernacle was given to him from above, and that it actually reflect the structure that
is in heaven. It's very, very interesting. And when you go to the book of Revelation, chapter 4 and 5,
you have St. John describing what the tabernacle in heaven is like. And here we have Jesus telling
Louisa that the saints in heaven looking at what is happening inside of us who are trying to live
the divine will, that they see the celestial fatherland. In other words, the whole structure of heaven
actually being recreated in our souls. If we had any idea what is happening, I think we would spend
every moment of every day just letting God do what he wants. And so Jesus continues,
"How could I not keep this soul guarded and not be extremely jealous of her if just one
act of hers is worth more than creation itself?" Now this is Jesus speaking, it's not me.
He says that one act in the divine will is worth more than the creation itself because
there is a spiritual creation being made, and each act is like putting another brick into that
spiritual building, building the New Jerusalem inside of us. And then of course, when enough
people on earth have allowed this to happen in them, you have the New Jerusalem on the earth,
and it's come down from heaven exactly as you have in the book of Revelation chapter 21.
And so the New Jerusalem is each single one of us, and it's very interesting when you go into
Revelation 21 when you are given the dimensions of the New Jerusalem. If you take the literal
measurement of the walls in furlongs, it's given. You'll find that the wall would be as long as
stretching from London to Sydney. In other words, it's going to be universal, that the New Jerusalem
will be all over the earth, that planet earth will have allowed heaven to come down and to let God
reign among us. It's way beyond what we can really grasp, but it's so wonderful. And so every act
that we make is essential to the building of that New Jerusalem. How could I not keep this soul
guarded, Jesus said, and not be extremely jealous of her if just one act of hers is worth more than
creation itself. In fact, the heavens and the sun in the sky are without intelligence,
and therefore they've no value in themselves. All the value Jesus said is mine. It's in the
Creator who actually made them. On the other hand, since one who lives in my will has an intelligence,
there is her will that runs within mine. And the power of my fiat uses it, that is, uses our will,
as raw material, in order to extend the new heavens. Now do you see that the Lord wants to
have something given to him so that he can make this new creation? If you go back to the gospels,
when Jesus wanted to multiply bread, he asked the apostles to give him something, to give him
a little piece of bread. It didn't matter how small it was, but just give it to him. And with that
small five loaves and two fish that they gave to him, he created the miracle of the loaves.
With the small piece of bread and drop of wine that was in front of him at the last supper,
he created the Eucharist, which extends universally and will do until the end of time.
And so the raw material that he wants to use to create the new Jerusalem, first of all inside of
us and then among us, is our will. And therefore the essential thing for us is to continuously
put our will down at the foot of God's throne. What I do every day is to say to our blessed mother,
well I say to Jesus that I put my will in the hands and in the immaculate heart of our blessed
mother so that she can put it at the foot of your throne every nanosecond, and that you would give
me a sip of your divine will as a result every nanosecond. So the gift has to be given all the
time, no break whatsoever. Because he says, "Since the one who lives in my will has an intelligence,
her will runs within mine and the power of my fiat uses her will as raw material in order to
extend these new heavens. Therefore, as the soul operates in my will, she gives me the delight of
forming new creations. Her acts are the manifestation of the life of my will, the tragedies of my
volition, my repeated fiat. So our acts with our will surrendered to him allows his fiat to be
repeated in us all the time, all the time, all the time. So I think we need to also say the word
fiat all the time. Yes, do it. Yes, be it done on to be according to your word, fiat,
miki, sakondum veribum to him. That we put our yes in union with our blessed mothers, yes,
in the divine will and offer it." And then he says, "How could I not love this soul?" Of course.
So August the 25th, 1921. The more knowledge one has about the divine will, the more value
the acts acquire. This is actually very important. If we don't understand what we're doing,
we're not going to use this material in the way it should be used. If I see a few pieces of colored
paper on a table and I don't have the instinct of an artist to do something with them,
they're only pieces of colored paper. But an artist could make something absolutely extraordinary
with them. If I have a few pieces of leftover food in the house and I'm not a good cook,
I don't have the instinct of the good cook. They're just pieces of leftover food. But if you're a
good cook, you can make something wonderful out of all those pieces. We have to know the value of
things. And so Jesus gives us an example of this in the next, in this message. So Louisa said,
"I was fusing all of myself in the holy divine volition. We need to say to Jesus continuously,
I fuse all of me in all of you all the time. I was fusing all of myself," she said. Jesus said,
"daughter of my will, the more you immerse yourself in my will, the more the circle of the human will
is enlarged within mine. It is yet true that the acts on in my will fill everything, just as the
light of the sun fills the earth. However, by repeating the act in my will, the circumference of
the sun itself becomes larger. The soul acquires greater intensity of light and heat, and as she
repeats her act in my will, her will remains tied to mine as many times. And these knots make many
divine rivelets flow over the whole earth, preventing the free course of justice." There's a lot there.
So let's go back. Jesus said, "The more you immerse yourself in my divine will, the more your will
is enlarged within mine. The extraordinary thing is, we think we're giving up our will.
We're actually putting it in the divine will." He says, "the more the circle of your will is enlarged
within mine. And yet it's true that the acts on in my will fill everything because they are divine,
just as the light of the sun fills the earth. However, by repeating the act in my will,
their circumference of the sun itself becomes larger. In other words, the soul expands and grows
as we do our acts in the divine will. That's where the growth is, continuously putting our will into
the divine will and continuously doing our acts in the divine will. That's where the growth actually
comes. And the soul acquires greater intensity of both light and heat. Now he's saying light and
heat because he's using the simile of the sun. But what he's saying is that we become more enlightened
and that our love becomes more intense. That's the light and the heat. "As she repeats her acts
in my will, her will remains tied to mine as many times. So each act in the divine will is another
not of our will clicked into the divine will. Until finally we are totally clicked in, permanently,
inseparably in the divine will. Just think of it as slotting a chain together. Until it's finally
fixed, the last click has gone in. "As she repeats her acts in my will, her will remains tied to mine
as many times. And these knots make many divine rivelets flow over the whole earth." So that means
the overflowing of grace to the whole earth. Everybody benefits from this. That's one of the
very attractive things about this divine will spirituality for me. It's that everybody benefits.
It doesn't matter who they are, what they are, what color they are, what race they are, what religion
they are, or whether they have any religion or not. Everybody is covered. It's beautiful.
I think of God as a father who has dozens of children and the children are of extraordinary
variety, not only of color and shape and size and intelligence and all the rest of it, but also
extraordinary variety of problems. Some of them are blind, some of them are deaf, some of them are
dumb, some of them are lame, some of them are sick, some of them are well, some of them seem not to
understand, and some of them seem to understand very well. But they're all his family. He loves
them all equally. And whenever there's food or lodging or love or anything else to be shared,
it's shared among them all. That's the way I think of God as the father of a large family.
And so anything we do in the divine will, it's for the entire family.
And not only that, but the entire family past, present and future. And so Jesus said,
it also prevents the free course of justice. In other words, our continuous repairing and
substituting for others, cams, chastisements. But Louisa objected and she said, "Ah, yes," she said,
"but many scourges fill the earth, such as to be horrifying." And we're dealing with August 1921,
and those scourges included the Civil War in Ireland in 1921 and the tearing apart of society.
It also included the Spanish Civil War, which was very frightening. And Jesus replied,
"My daughter, yet, one can say that this is still nothing. And if it wasn't for these
rivelets, for these knots of the human will made in the divine will, I would look at the
earth as if it didn't belong to me anymore. And therefore, I would make chasms open everywhere
to swallow it. Oh, how the earth weighs on me." Wow. In other words, Louisa is looking at the thing
from a very narrow canvas. It's from her own position, from her own little town of Corrato,
and her own little country of Italy. She's not looking at it universally, as God is. Therefore,
she cannot see the terrible evils that are on the earth. She may not have known the two wars that
I've just mentioned to you in Ireland and Spain. And they wouldn't have been the only ones. They're
just the ones who come to my mind. She's not aware of the full picture. And therefore, she thinks that
our divine will acts are not having such a big effect after all. I don't think this is Louisa's
problem. In later volumes, the Lord tells her that he allowed her to have all kinds of problems
because she would be voicing our problems and the way we think and the doubts that we have,
that our acts would make all that difference. And so Jesus has to tell us that we don't see it on
a big enough canvas and that we can't see the way he sees. Now, what he says at the end of this
paragraph is frightening. He said, "If these little knots of the human will and the divine will
weren't actually made," he said, "I would make chasms open up everywhere to swallow it,
to swallow the earth." Now, this reminds me of Genesis chapter 6 verses 1 to 2, where you're told
that the Lord regretted having made man, that there was nothing only evil in the heart of man
all the time. And that at that particular point, he decided on the frightening cleansing of the
earth, which was the flood. But as we speak in 2020, this is century later, and the world is
infinitely worse than it was. We haven't learned anything from the World Wars. Sin and evil is
totally accepted as normal. Anything that's own Christian, they seem to celebrate. Anything that's
Christian, they seem to repudiate. So we're in a much worse position. Louisa would have been
completely horrified to know that society and the church could have reached this particular
stage. And therefore, the stimulus is therefore on us to make repeated acts in the divine will
to do what we can to hold back that frightening chastisement which is coming,
or at least to mitigate it if we can't hold it back. Louisa said, "Jesus spoke with such bitterness
that it would make the stones cry." Because after all, he paid for every single sin. He forgave
everybody officially from the cross. His heart was opened to give us all the sacraments. No wonder he
would speak with bitterness. And so he said, "Every time I speak to you about my will and you acquire
new understanding and knowledge, your act in my will receives more value and you acquire
much more riches." Now, look at that. Every time I speak to you about my will, that means the more
we study this material and the more we understand it, the more deeply we will actually be able to
pray and intercede, knowing the value of what we're doing. And when we know the value of what we're
doing, we will do it from a much greater depth of faith and love and therefore it'll have much
greater value. Let me read that for you again. "Every time I speak to you about my will and you acquire
new understanding and knowledge, your act in my will receives more value and you acquire more
immense riches." He says, "For example, if you take a man who possesses a gem and he knows that
this gem is worth the penny." He's only a rich one penny. In other words, if he sees that the value
of this thing is small, then it is small for him. Now, it happens that he shows this gem to a skilled
expert who tells him that the gem is worth 5,000 pounds, lira, dollars, whatever, euros. The man
no longer possesses one penny. He now possesses 5,000 of whatever currency. And then he goes on and he
gets an opportunity to show the gem to another expert, even more experienced, who assures him that
it's 100,000 of that currency. Therefore, he's 100,000 times more rich than he was in the beginning.
And the only thing that is of any difference is his knowledge of the value of the gem.
It's a wonderful example that Jesus gives. So, according to his knowledge of the value of the gem,
the man becomes richer and feels greater love and appreciation for the gem. He keeps it in custody
more jealously knowing that the gem is his entire fortune. See, we have to come to the point of
realizing that the divine will is it. This is heaven's treasure. This is our most extraordinary
privilege of being able to help the whole human race. It's not a trifle. But as Jesus says,
the gem hasn't changed. It's the same as it was in the beginning. The one who has changed
is the man who now appreciates it. And that's what happens to us when we study these writings,
that the more we study them, the more we come to appreciate the extraordinary gift that God has
given to us. Now, the same happens with my will, as well as with the virtues. According to how the
soul understands their value and acquires the knowledge of them, she comes to acquire new values
and new riches in her acts. I want to give you Ephesians 321. God wants to do more for us than we
could ever ask or imagine. Therefore, the more you know my will, the more your act will acquire value.
Or if you knew what sees of grace as I open it up between me and you, every time I speak to you
about the effects of my will, you would die of joy and you would make feast as if you had acquired
new kingdoms. So Jesus said that every time he speaks to us about his will, and that means for us,
reading and studying. Every time we read and study what Jesus has given to us, he says,
whole new seas of graces are poured into us. We need to come to understand this. We need to
come to grasp it. We need to come to appreciate it and to use it. I'll stop there.